Freud thanks for joining us good morning
how are you hey good morning Dan I'm
doing great always got to be on take me
back to your rookie season as a
quarterback as we try to put all this in
perspective with what dak Prescott is
doing granted granted it's it's it's a
different era a new game but what were
you like well he's 15 more games already
how rude is it well it was it was pretty
rough I mean I I didn't have this office
of life that he's is lying and running
game and all that they've had around him
but it would haven't said that and even
with the fire of knowing that we've
sitting one quarterbacks with and
quarterback step in here in the last
10-15 years and have success but you
know here's a guy who's a fourth-round
pick he wasn't it first i'll pick he
wasn't the first overall guy and was
regarded as a project when he was
crafted I'm over talking to Jason
Garrett at the time that they did pick
him in the fourth round it and even in
visiting with Dax before the season
opener his first NFL start he said that
in college you're you know he had never
taken staffs out of Center you've never
run play-action passes and that was the
thing that he had to get over the most
that he had to learn how to do and the
biggest adjustment for him when he did
get to the NFL and what you watch him it
looks like he's been doing it his entire
life so he's a very impressive young man
he's a mature for his age must be he
wants to be great he wants to be
successful and puts in a lot of time but
to see how he has gone out played in
what defenses are kinda confusing wrong
quarterback has been really impressive I
don't know what more we can say about
his performance it's just I don't do
nothing really and dan has happened in
the second half of the season opener yes
your Giants I thought myself judging him
like a veteran quarterback in his first
NFL start just because of the way you
know he handled himself on the field of
the poison he showed can he win the job
can he win the job yeah I think he has
won the job uh I just go tell he's 15 at
419 games that he has started but he's
respite number of games all I played the
14-gauge needle in the last video
20-something so I just think that as I
said yesterday in the broadcaster to get
the momentum and confidence if this tool
is currently playing with it is hard to
do and why they were risk you know
disrupting that momentum that they have
is beyond me and I don't think that they
will there was a time just a couple of
weeks ago that i thought when tony was
helping they would go back to him but
that was before they plate Cincinnati
last week and I think most people they
included felt that okay now he's going
to play a really good team the crow a
playoff team in Cincinnati they passed
that test they played great they
embarrassed Cincinnati defensively and
then they have to go on alone against
the packers in lambeau and these are
gonna be some real test will do not only
will get an idea as to what Jack is good
idea just to where this team old and
they dismantled green baize yesterday so
every test that he's been given he has
passed with flying colors I can't
imagine uh that I can't imagine him not
being the guy how you sell that to the
rest clapping part the way that they are
well how does Tony Romo play this or
should he play this well I think that
Joe Torre will be happy about it the
same thing happened to me and 91 Steve
Beuerlein stepped in with 15 straight
related to the playoffs I was healthy
but it still once again in the
postseason Jimmy said we're sticking
with the hot hand I didn't like it and
don't like it either it doesn't take
long you know once you remove yourself
from the situation are able to actually
look at it objectively I think that you
know I have a short period of time
realize that any German made the right
call and I think that's what the head
coats of a staff has to do but I think
Tony will handle it with class I assume
events to learn the cowboys go but it
but I do believe but at some point this
season they're going to be Tony Romo
whether that's because that gets hurt
mr. game or two or if he has to come off
the bench and play I know back in 2001
when when Bill Belichick decided to
stick with Tom Brady they had to go with
blood so in the AFC Championship game to
help them win that game so he'll get his
opportunity again and maybe you know who
those you never know what the injury
situation maybe if it occurs with dak
and he made quite a plan more than
people anticipated this time Troy Aikman
of Fox she's got the Vikings and the
Eagles coming up next weekend joining us
Dan Patrick show I just mentioned ten
minutes ago that you have to look at
Ezekiel Elliott more than just rookie of
the year but I know it's early but I'm I
have to throw it out there that he's in
an MVP conversation I would imagine yes
okay not good I said no I grew that
completely he's someone he stays healthy
it's hard to imagine him not leading the
league in rushing when it's all said
done actually I'd even set some records
before it's all over with offensive line
is outstanding I think they've gotten
even better when well towns got injured
is out for probably the rest of the
season left guard but this guy Ezekiel
Elliott he's the total package he's a
home run threat you know because of his
speed but yet he's tossing runs between
the tackles he catch the ball and pass
protect well I I didn't spent a long
time I can't think of anyone that comes
to mind that ISIL step into the league
at this age and all the things that he
does not just well he doesn't
exceptionally well he's played and all
those areas and and that's difficult for
for any young player especially running
back in pass protection but he does a
great job how surreal was it to be at
Lambeau Brett Favre comes in the booth
and Aaron Rodgers is struggling mightily
and it felt like you were choosing your
words carefully trying to say something
positive about Aaron Rodgers yeah it was
great to see Brett number one he's been
a long time so random and the reaction
that he got in half time it was in that
cloud was ready to celebrate and for a
lot of reasons and and they weren't
given the opportunity outside of
it's his halftime ceremony yeah you
would have liked to have gotten into
some things with Brett about Aaron and
and what he has seen from him in terms
of his pool yeah but I didn't feel like
that was the time based on the way that
the game was being played a Laird's day
was going it was kind of always to have
him there and and I noticed pakistan's
whether they were all my station were
thrilled at Lambeau as well what do you
think of all these celebrations then the
flags that go along with it some are
flagged in some aren't but are there
more celebrations or we just focused on
these celebrations though the
celebrations with regards to what
touchdowns penalties uh yeah I saw a
video just last week or two from the
league office with celebrations and you
know I kind of I understand where
they're going i go back when Terrell
Owens was playing and pulling out shark
until cameras and all that kind of stuff
I thought cut a little bit carried away
I just comment on this last week it's
interesting to bring it up but yeah I
remember watching the Washington
Redskins know the fun bumps you and the
celebration that they had when they
score touchdowns and that was great as a
young girl you know boy I remember those
moments and how exciting that was in and
take that type of stuff out of the game
I don't want there's a lot about the
game they're like that but I don't like
right now but blah I don't know it's a
different game overall on I played and
that's going to continue for obvious
reasons and uninterested as anyone to
see what this game looks like you're
another 10 15 years down the road what
else bothers you about the game well I
just think that their number one that
you know for instance with pliers for
are different things and sometimes it's
hard to understand exactly how they come
up with the numbers that they do if
you're going to find a player I'd like
to see the signs announced on Monday and
get them over with instead we tend to
care about the fines and a mouse on
Friday fridays
when that stuff is behind us and we
should be talking about the game that
we're about to go in and call or they
were about to be played you know that
weekend I think we should bogged down
and too much more fall I think too you
know obviously the safety rules I
understand or try to make the game as
safe as possible but I think from a
fan's perspective you know on
quarterbacks for instance when he's
pointing you know touches of the helmet
and penalties that are called to impact
the game and the outcomes of the games
its first time for me as a former player
even with safety in mind that I and I
know it's frustrating for the hands it
can instant replay we have a sentry
plenty of the calls right and I think we
still even after instant replay in a
place review we come away from games at
times thinking all that wasn't the right
call over that he did it right so
there's a lot of different things that
that concern me about the game or i'd
like to see maybe had in a different
direction but you know we're kind of
where we're at some of which is never
going to change Jimmy can find no yeah i
got fine i left the pro bowl early back
exactly nineteen ninety-three i think it
was i left at halftime to catch a flight
home I got summoned into the
commissioner's office in New York and
Lee sniper was my agent and so did I
hate the Commissioner uh taglib you at
the time he wants you to tend to New
York I said Lee I'm not going to fly
over in New York just a I'm telling he's
finally says wrong she wants to be so
funny if he wants to talk to you about
being a goodwill ambassador to the NFL
ago I was in that office for at least
two hours and I can I should tell you
Doris 10 well ambassador never came out
of his office it was a it was a good but
chillin for as long as I was in there
and I got time so it was a long trip
photos get burned a lot of money a safe
travels I was great to talk to you have
fun thanks for joining us Troy great
thanks man all right that's Troy Aikman
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you